I'm Bradford Shellhammer and I travel the world helping businesses unleash their creativity.
That's what I do for a living,...
...which is not a real job but it works for me.
I feel like I discover a creative solution to problems every single day,...
...but the creative solution for me...
...was to actually not control or micromanage everything in my life.
And I realized that creative individuals and creative professionals are much better...
...and much more productive when they empower people around them...
...to actually do the work rather than try and hold everything so close to them.
So, something I've really learned the last couple of years...
..is how to unleash or allow the creativity of other people to outshine my own.
And together we build something that one single designer and/or creative person couldn't do.